- Ich bin viel zu spät!
Normalerweise bin ich nicht so unpünktlich.
- Hallo, Lisa!
- Hallo!
- Na, wie geht's?
- Geht so. Der Verkehr ist eine Katastrophe.
Und ich war eine halbe Stunde im Stau.
- Stau?
- Ja, Stau. Ähm, das heißt,
es sind zu viele Autos auf den Straßen.
Es geht alles sehr langsam ...
Äh, Nico braucht ein Zimmer.
- Ach ja, eure Wohnung wird renoviert.
- Ja, unsere Heizung ist kaputt.
Und Nawin, Nina, Sebastian und ich
fahren übermorgen in Urlaub.
- Das Hostel?
- Es sind keine Zimmer mehr frei.
- Keine Zimmer?
- Nein, Alle Zimmer sind reserviert.
Keine Chance.
- Oh, nein!
- Wie lange bleibst du denn in Deutschland?
- Nicos Tasche und sein Pass sind
immer noch weg.
- Das ist wirklich ein Problem.
- Hostel, Papperlapapp!
Ich habe doch Platz.
Der nette junge Mann kann gern
ein paar Tage bei mir wohnen.
- Inge!
- Komm einfach vorbei.
Hier ist meine Adresse.
- Danke, Frau …
- Inge, mein Lieber!
Also, bis morgen dann!
- Bis morgen!
- Tschüss!
- Danke Frau Inge, mein Lieber!